is George Pickens underrated
he laid out Clint
[Music]
welcome to underrated the only show that
improves the video game ratings of your
favorite professional athletes today
behind me the tenacious rookie wide
receiver for the Pittsburgh Steelers
George Pickens
[Music]
all right so your whole life you
probably played Madden yeah and now
you're in the NFL are you excited to see
yourself in the game yeah what is that
gonna be like it's gonna be kind of
crazy because you know we didn't really
have NCAA no [ __ ] it's gonna be fun to
play with yourself in a game even though
I'm gonna be you know Ricky you're
expecting your ratings to be low yeah
will it upset you when you see how low
they are will you use that as motivation
uh it won't accept me unless it was like
OD like if I was like a 50 or something
like that it wouldn't really understand
because it's expected as a rookie yes I
wish I was already like 85 right yeah I
don't think I can get you to that yeah
but I do have a guy that can get you up
a little bit okay so let's bring Clint
Oldenburg in get over here Clint
[Music]
where are we right now with George well
we're really excited to see George play
this year his catch ratings are actually
pretty high he's in the mid 80s for all
of our catch he's actually one of the
top three ranked receivers in all those
categories but sir out of rookies of all
the rookies 85 84 85 range for sure
catching as a rookie I love that right
so what can we work on today well we
want to look at Rocky okay so there's
two main ratings that we're looking at
so first is impact blocking yeah 47 so
that's 90th among all NFL wide receivers
not just rookies okay and then the
second one is hit power now this is the
one that needs the most work yeah hip
power right now is only an 18. yeah
I'm gonna get that up 18 18. mine would
be an 18. I think you might be like a
eight We're not gonna get into that now
so we can improve hip power and impact
blocking yes sir okay are you ready to
do this let's do it yeah let's mess
these ratings up let's do it eight
all right George we have a gauntlet of
obstacles try and maintain your line
block them as you go through and Destroy
these at the end I want to see Full
anger okay with the clock going we're
doing speed we're doing power three two
one go
oh
[Music]
my God
he's still smashing
[Music]
he laid out Clint he sold out horizontal
my guy Pickens power
[Music]
I was very impressed how did it feel it
felt great how did you feel about that
sold out at the at the tackle point that
was great but I think if you give it one
more try you might even be faster yeah I
think I think I should give it another
try as well you think so yeah it might
be better speed I like that commitment
all right get out there let's do it
destroy them
[Music]
here we go George three two one go
oh
see how far the balls are going this
time I'm always ready for it yes
no let's go you got that how fast 10
seconds 10 seconds it's pretty good
I felt like that time you knew that they
were coming at you yeah I felt like they
were flying and then you still laid out
again you did that in in 10 seconds wow
how did you feel about your performance
I felt like I did better than the last
time he's writing a lot I like to
all right so what are we thinking here
all right so that second run was even
better than the first yes it was it's a
10 second run pretty good he didn't even
have to do that but he did it for you
nailed every ball and actually hit some
people with yeah they looked like they
got hurt right so
I think we might have some adjustments
to me here's the question that I love to
ask he says Hey Clint Oldenburg
is George Pickens underrated George
Pickens is underrated
tell us how much he's underrated it's
George Pickens come on where was he
Clinton all right so where's he going
Clint George was 47 in Impact block yes
and even though he did a great job with
those balls we're going up just one
point in Impact blocking 248 that ties
him with Drake London as the number one
rated rookie wide receiver number one
rookie wide receiver number one rookie
now because of the aggressiveness shown
on the tackle dummy over there we're
gonna go up plus three on hit power yeah
all right so we're now going into Madden
23 we're gonna be a 21 hit power with
receivers
hit power you do not want to mess with
George Pickens he's got an impact block
you he's gonna hit power and he is what
underrated underrated most importantly
let's go George
[Music]